since its inception in 2010 the walking
dead has earned its place as a
long-running tv classic
despite its overwhelming popularity
though it's by no means immune to
criticism
we're here to show you some unpopular
opinions about the walking dead that
raise good points
we're definitely not the first to notice
that the walking dead plays like an
inverted star trek according to the
imagination of gene roddenberry
post-current civilization humanity
cooperates
prospers and revels in scientific
advancement
and exploration meanwhile people in the
walking dead universe form tribes and go
to war against each other instead of
pooling their resources and working
together against an
obvious and omnipresent common threat
while star trek is optimistic the
walking dead goes a step beyond
pessimism into full-blown nihilism
for whoever's left of the gang their
victories don't really matter because
they live in a world that's already been
conquered by walkers
they just survive terrible things in
order to survive more terrible things
therefore if the series ends with
anything other than all the characters
becoming dinner
it will have betrayed its central themes
of futility and doom
considering the fact that the writers
have sometimes significantly deviated
from the graphic novels trajectory
there's no way of knowing if this
inevitable conclusion will come to pass
on screen
at one point in 2006's clerks 2 the
character of randall graves goes on a
little diatribe to explain his contempt
for the lord of the rings trilogy
as he puts it all it was was a bunch of
people walking
well if you replace walking with killing
zombies in randall's rant
it's not an inaccurate description of
the walking dead we're definitely not
saying the show has ever gotten boring
in order to get truly boring it would
have to reduce its seasonal body count
to a degree that would make it a
different show entirely
but it goes without saying that things
have gotten repetitive
rick and the crew struggle against the
elements until they find the green
family farm
after walkers over on the farm the
heroes set out on their own once again
then they come to the prison and they
live there until walkers take over that
one too
same deal in alexandria in other words
the walking dead has a formula and it
sticks to that formula pretty closely
if a corporation makes a successful
thing it could be a tv show
film book what have you then its next
step will be to recreate whatever that
thing happened to be in hopes of similar
monetary rewards
in a vacuum that's not a bad impulse
it's why film genres exist in the first
place
but we've hit a point where big
companies fear taking risks on just
about anything they don't think is a
surefire hit
for proof look no further than the world
of the walking dead
after all fear the walking dead the
walking dead world beyond
and any other dead adjacent television
projects and development exist
at the expense of an unknowable number
of other shows that weren't greenlit
because they lacked a built-in audience
perhaps we shouldn't judge amc too
harshly for its decision-making process
because that's also
why we got better call saw but it is
worth asking at what point do we no
longer require expansions on a story
that gets accused of redundancy and
spinning its wheels as often as the
walking dead
are the walking dead fans all jerks of
course not
but there's a significant minority among
the phantom that's pretty toxic
for proof look no further than josh
mcdermott's social media experience
the actor has received death threats
because some fans dislike the character
he plays the cowardly eugene
of course if mcdermott responded in kind
to each and every crazed fan who
threatened his life over the actions of
an imaginary person he plays on
television then mcdermott would look
insane and that would interfere with his
ability to gain further employment
as a hollywood actor his only other
option was to quit social media and we
can't say we blame him
mcdermott's far from the only cast
member to deal with online strife
sadly fans body shamed alana masterson
prompting both the actress and her
co-star stephen og to strike back
encouraging trolls to quote go and do
something productive with your life
when michonne hawthorne first appears at
the end of season two we see her leading
around two walkers on leashes
later we find out that these are the
re-animated corpses of her boyfriend
and her boyfriend's pal evidently she
mutilated their bodies due to some
justified resentment connected to the
death of her son
but in the process michonne discovered
that walkers become docile
and harmless once their mouths and arms
are removed
even better she learned that surrounding
herself with armless mouthless walkers
rendered her invisible to actively
hostile zombies
so why isn't every living person
dragging a pair of neutered walkers with
them at all times
if there's an effective method of walker
deterrent available why is michonne the
only person who ever uses it
furthermore why does she only use it
when it's supposed to symbolize her
paranoia and isolation
this is a list of opinions of course it
could very well be that people don't
want to stand next to mutilated walkers
24 7 because that would be a completely
disgusting way to live
but once you got used to it in our
opinion being constantly safe from
walkers is worth being constantly
grossed out by walkers
let's talk about october of 2016. fans
had waited all summer to find out whose
skull negan would shatter
at the onset of the seventh season the
season premiere started and we all held
on to our butts anticipating a payoff
that would validate all our theories and
arguments over who had the best guess
after a handful of eternal minutes we
watched both abraham
and glenn face immensely unpleasant
blunt force deaths
and it was gory disturbingly so
and there's something strange about the
fact that the show made us wait
so long made us debate and wonder and
speculate only to treat us to a truly
brutal beatdown that left us all feeling
queasy
granted nobody on the walking dead is
ever safe that looming uncertainty is
written into the genre's dna
but in the lead up to season seven the
uncertainty gave way to a kind of sadism
that one might use to promote
a snuff film and that raises
uncomfortable questions
you are not safe
why were we so excited to watch someone
die is there something wrong with us do
we need help
and did the show step over the line with
those brutal killings
so if you tell us rick grimes seems like
a nice guy you'll get no argument
the protagonist played by andrew lincoln
sticks by his friends and family and
always tries to do the honorable thing
but perhaps by design he's not what we'd
call a fascinating individual
in fact as a sheriff's deputy with a
wife and a child in suburban georgia he
was living a pretty typical life before
the world ended
circumstances in subsequent years
inspired considerable intensity from
grimes but there's not a ton else that
makes him feel intrinsically unique
he didn't rise out of an abusive
relationship like carol he's not the
most charismatic person in the room at
all times allah daryl
he isn't an awesome swordsman like
michonne he doesn't even have a
memorable gimmick like jesus or ezekiel
in some respects he's similar to john
connor in the terminator franchise
the other characters look to rick grimes
as a leader and they clearly draw a
tremendous amount of inspiration from
his words and deeds
but nobody ever gets all that specific
about what precisely makes this guy so
special
ultimately this places rick grimes in
the same category as buffy summers and
jerry seinfeld
thoroughly effective main characters who
are nevertheless bland
as dishwater when compared to all of
their friends
the series premiered in 2010 about a
year before the emergence of its
contemporaries game of thrones and once
upon a time
these ensemble dramas all felt designed
to fill the void left by lost which
infamously dangled solutions to the
island's many mysteries inches in front
of its audience's proverbial face
throughout six seasons
likewise the walking dead gang's journey
in season one to the centers for disease
control and prevention led us to assume
the origin of the infection might be
explained at some point
since then many seasons have aired and
in all that time characters have rarely
expressed interest
in any big picture beyond immediate
necessity and it seems unlikely that
anybody still
tuning in expects to find out what
started the zombie apocalypse
one could argue that attaching a
clear-cut cause for the end of
civilization undercuts the themes of
random suffering in mayhem that permeate
throughout the rest of the show
so if the series never explains where
the walker infection came from
it won't be a worse show for allowing
its big mystery to go unsolved
in fact it's probably safer to leave
that particular rock unturned rather
than offering up
a disappointing explanation that wasn't
even needed to begin with
as we learned in september of 2020
season 11 of the walking dead will be
its last
regardless of how the spin-offs have
turned out or will turn out amc made a
good decision here
in fact if they made a mistake at all it
was not lopping off the show's aging
head a few years earlier
in fact why would amc ever continue a
beloved sci-fi horror series well after
its quality and fan interest started to
decline
did amc executives not learn the tragic
lesson of the x-files
when it started in 1993 the x-files
became a surprise pop cultural phenomena
much like the walking dead wood years
later
also like the walking dead the x-files
probably should have tied off
all its loose story threads and called
it a day sometime around season five or
six
instead the network dragged it out for
nine seasons and two movies plus a
revival years later
seasons 10 and 11 aren't complete and
total garbage but their worst entries
particularly the cringe inducing my
struggle 4
are bafflingly terrible to a degree that
damages the legacy of the entire series
in its defense the walking dead has
never produced an episode as abysmal as
my struggle 4
but the show won't have officially
dodged that bullet until it ends
calling it quits at season 11 was a good
albeit belated decision
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one